let's get to reciprocals this will be
where we finished today okay we again we
know what these look like right but
there are just two very simple ideas
which we can express in an analytical
you know an algebraic way it will help
us unpack what's going on so firstly if
I have a function right and I know it's
equal to zero and what will happen to
its reciprocal
well it'll be the reciprocal of zero
which doesn't exist right and what that
corresponds to on our graphs is you're
pretty much gonna expect a vertical
asymptote okay okay so if you've got a
function at zero at a particular point
then it's reciprocal has a variable
they're going to coincide at that
particular point where it's zero right
then correspondingly right if what
function is growing if it's racing off
with no limit in sight it's going to
infinity then what happens to their
reciprocal well it's all the denominator
that thing that's going to infinity so
therefore it's going to approach zero
right now you have to be careful I'm I
approach it for above or below that
would depend on the side of the whole
thing let's use there's two very simple
building blocks and how they go this way
y equals 1 over X minus 2 okay
wait you have a look at this I've drawn
X minus 2 as a computer graphic so my
reciprocal
he's gonna have one of these
so for example here is the first
important point I notice this like here
right the function is zero in there so
when I think about its reciprocal I want
to be expecting why can't exist there
something apartment a vertical asymptote
through there do you favor that okay now
when you have a look over here ah I'm
going off to infinity right and there's
no limitation on it okay
so when I take the reciprocal of
something that's growing it's gonna come
down to zero do you agree with that so
therefore I'm doing that over on the
left hand side I observed the exact same
thing but it's going to approach from
the bottom because will be a small up up
it'll be a small negative number does
that make sense so I have this asymptote
horizontally on both sides now these are
the very important horizontal messages
you're already familiar with because of
a hyperbola right but it's not just
because it's a hyperbola right you're
using this thought process to figure out
what the ordinance of do it okay
so now I'm gonna graphically right have
a look over here I've got a really
really big positive values and that's
why I'm coming towards here I'm dropping
down like a draw but then as I go
towards the left towards x equals two
the denominator is shrinking its
vanishing away right so it's going to
become one over zero point one whatever
0.001 it's gonna style
that's what it's doing it over on the
left same argument but a couple of
things I could do it right actually
no keys here I actually have numbers so
for instance see that
what's that intercept there that's
negative two right so when I take its
reciprocal I should go to what the
intercept is what's the reciprocal of
negative 2 its negative 1/2 right now I
actually have to go where that is
because I've said that's negative 2 so I
multiply self into a buddy who scales
do you notice that so that's negative 2
there's negative one so there's negative
1 or 2 I have to pass through there
right like the visual has to make your
basis of that so therefore let's see
there you go that's actually a critical
point if I'm saying that's negative to
that negative aha has to be there
it can't be somewhere else and be
consistent with my vertical scale does
that make sense okay now stand on photo
else been born something like this guy
UCI Cross will be chosen the guys that
we just did over there right so let's
just dorky views out to pretty brown and
then we get down to see
you already know when explants x-rayed
by statute okay so now I'm going to
approach this in the same way right I
look at the points where my function by
component function is zero and there are
two of it which means I've got two
vertical asymptotes right let's draw
them in
okay now again I'm going to look for my
important places in torture places so
for instance I actually don't there's a
special pointy on right and I can fairly
easily work out it's valued right the x
value is 1 so what's the Y value what's
the ordinate
I'm just thinking like a completely
function by the way I can actually think
about what is the courtiers it's gonna
be one and one takeaway 2 is negative 1
right so that's what is 1 negative 1 the
order is the pot I'm interested in
what's the reciprocal of negative 1 its
negative 1 right so therefore my actual
graph is also going to pass through that
point and that's important to me I've
said it's been just like I said this
intercept was there right so to say
possibly then you can see that behavior
you can understand the behavior now
right ok what's happening well I've got
notes I appreciate zero right on each
side keep my composure graphically so
the components approaches zero what's
the reciprocal of that village where
it's going to approach infinity right
but the airport I'm negative yet thank
you so I'm approaching negative infinity
which of course we could have known by
throwing regions but because of
approaching this in this way I don't
need regions right you go towards
negative 50 cent there is my breath now
on the outsides of those regions I can
use the same arguments that I have here
and these graphs are off and going
towards positive fit it is no boundary
alert they're just going to go forever
okay so therefore when you take the
reciprocal of those they're going to
shrink they're gonna come towards zero
so that's where my horizontal asymptote
comes from right you see the denominator
that's my green graph the determinate is
getting huge
so the actual graph the reciprocal that
is getting smaller so that's how you get
these graphs that are gonna come back
here now I should really be a motion for
my points of intersection but you can
find those men on
these checks here so now you have
another analytical tool but at this
shape but it's like think about the
reciprocals think about now they
actually forcing themselves to behave
okay now one last one
yep peppy timing and I will do this
really quickly we're gonna do cur SEC X
now we're gonna think it exactly the
same way let's draw it from naught to
360 will do not to 360
okay so really quickly that's cracked is
because look too much fun that right I
would look for important points right
immediately I see three important points
screaming out of me
what are they I've gotten zero rights
right I've got roots
I've got x-intercepts so zero degrees
180 degrees 360 degrees the function
right Y cosine X which is actually what
I'm envisioning Yeah right
sine X is zero all of those points so
that means when I take the reciprocal
I'm getting those vertical asymptotes
yeah
I don't is trying to talk about okay
now I've got those in place that's great
can anyone else suggest maybe some other
important points on here yeah some of
those turning points right now again
because you have the distinct advantage
of knowing exactly where those turning
points are right number one you've got
next value let's finish it maybe 90
degrees so what's the value there what's
the ordinate it's one right what's the
reciprocal of one one so therefore my
reciprocal function also passes through
there then it's got to grow do you see
that down here my coordinate will be
negative one what's the reciprocal of
negative one also negative one so
therefore you now have the pretty graph
of cosine